[Musique]
ils viennent tout juste de poser les
pieds à vancouver et déjà on sent leur
soulagement des noms qu'on voit la voie
du doing what you speak in encore en ce
moment explique chris o tu dois faire
attention à tout ce que tu dis tout ce
que tu fais on la peur c'est horrible
crise qui est née au canada via hong
kong depuis plus de vingt ans il a
convaincu son ami tchang wing rogue de
faire une demande d'immigration à
vancouver il ya un système de convaincre
il est temps de revenir dit-il
en ce moment il ya beau avoir deux
millions de personnes dans la rue le
gouvernement local ne réagit pas
moi j'ai beaucoup de chance d'être
citoyen canadien et pouvoir parti partir
c'est aussi ce qu'a décidé de faire
jenny lio il ya quatre ans déjà à
l'époque dit-elle
on sentait l'emprise de plus en plus
forte du gouvernement chinois depuis des
années explique t-elle les autorités
veulent changer le système d'éducation
en comme pour le copier à celui de la
chine
et puis en plus des raisons politiques
il y aussi la qualité de vie qui s'est
lentement détériorée depuis qu'on est
passé sous le contrôle de pékin en 1997
ajoute génie de plus en plus de chinois
viennent en touristes ou des ménages la
population de la région a augmenté de
25% depuis la rétrocession et bien des
hongkongais se plaignent du coût de lève
toujours plus élevés mais à vancouver
aussi les prix de l'immobilier sont
exorbitants et arriver en masse de hong
kong et pourrait réchauffer le marché
[Musique]
déjà dans les dernières semaines
explique ce gestionnaire immobilier
on a vu beaucoup plus d'acheteurs de
hong kong on commence à voir une
quatrième vague d'immigration chinoise
au canada dit-il
il ya ceux qui sont venus il ya plus de
100 ans pour construire le chemin de fer
ceux qui ont quitté encore avant la
rétrocession en 1997
et puis les immigrants de chine
territoriales
partir des années 2000 et là c'est la
nouvelle vague une vague encore
difficile à quantifier puisque bien des
ressortissants ont déjà un passeport
canadien aurait aimé nos ponts faire
partie de cette vague que l'on rende
compte qu'il a connus restent intactes
mais il faut maintenant ses espoirs sur
sa nouvelle vie au canada
ici leur enceinte et radio canada
vancouver